hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the forest now I got
a ton of requests to play this again
probably more than any other game and
there were two major updates since the
last time I played it so I made a list
of the new features that I want to get
to the new things that I want to see and
the new things that I want to not do
because I'd prefer not to do them so
anyway number one sharks were added I'm
gonna punch one in the face no matter
what I'm gonna punch the shark don't
care what it takes
number two there's a surprise added to
the yacht where me and our mando we're
staying number three you can kill the
birds with fire so obviously I wanna
kill as many birds as fire as possible
number four I want to build a cabin
number five I can't count I want to
build it or destroy an enemy village and
number six I want to not die so I can
pretty much cross that one off the list
right now or like eliminate it because
I'm probably gonna die alive if anything
happened to you or this plane I would be
incredibly devastated but more
specifically anyway so I'm back in the
game what this is mostly gonna be cuz a
lot of these objectives might be hard
expect a little what the hell is that do
I have a pedometer a pedo meter so I
even detect the pedo bear in the woods
the one who kidnapped my son hmm that's
really interesting though that's a cool
feature I wonder if that oh no I sell
the bar on the side so I was wondering
if that was gonna like track my stats
and how many calories I was yeah burning
throughout the day and how many I needed
to eat anyway Peter close I will close
that later sorry lady I'm gonna need
this for probably dying god I didn't
mean to I didn't see that there were
poison please don't kill me I just
started the game I don't know any better
I'm a stupid tourist who landed on an
island loan with no survival skills
Oh kitty tim-tim oh wait no you can't
you're kidding up by cannibals alright
so we are overlooking lake bug-out over
there but they did say that they improve
some things about this game so I'm just
gonna assume that they might have
actually fixed this so either way I'm
gonna head towards the beach first but
first I'm gonna try to bash
open all these get what I can out of him
bunk
Yahoo yarr oh look it's a camp of people
good thing I'm low on health and about
to die because I was stupid enough to
eat poison well you look all looks like
you're having fun over here I'm just
gonna destroy your f oh gee I can't
destroy it okay y'all y'all have a nice
day y'all y'all take care now
oh you trees mmm I can feel ya I'm gonna
chop into you I'm gonna slice you open
and touch ya that sounded a lot weirder
than I wanted to and I wanted it to
sound weird all right so my first
objective is to find a beach set up a
camp get ready to punch some sharks
maybe find a yacht and then see what we
can do about not dying well that's a
nice ominous sound leg if only you were
unarmed just not sound good
why is that sound so bad and dangerous
am I in trouble okay bye oh that lasted
for a whole two seconds oh you're trying
to hold out on me uh-huh
oh yeah I'm glad there's all this change
strewn about and that's gonna be awfully
useful bird you're ready to die bird
bonk you didn't die did you flew away
so majestically I'll kill you someday
then you surely are gonna pay it's not
gonna get me any closer to punching them
sharks what the hell is that god I keep
thinking that the bushes when they're on
low-res distance motor actually people
you're not people you're not even human
wait a minute what's that over there
dead body Wow
why why is there dead body here why do
you have fish strapped you all those are
bones you have bones strapped to your
crotch I thought it was fish not weird
you carry on you scamper you oh whoa did
I find a cave oh my god I found a cave
everybody I want to go in there but
first I want to actually set up a base
and I remember this this is where the
infamous markiplier went totally bonkers
ooh I've got a fishing pole oh my god I
can actually survive here this is great
I'm gonna survive a little bit up here
off the beach
you know just a little bit hidden in the
woods so that I know that I'll be able
to that rain sound is really good
all right now fooling around trying to
earn the bacon trying to bring home the
bacon trying to eat the bacon trying to
fish up some bacon I really want some
bacon right now I'm very hungry this
tree is so thick ha okay I'm done oh
[ __ ] you oh yeah we'll get this tree
much more meteor hell is there okay no
one good oh my god what was that
rabbit rabbit no come here that's what
am i doing I'm so slow
rabbit buddy bunny rabbit come here
ready for you yes huh oh I got it oh
yeah gross I didn't actually expect to
get that another bunny rabbit I see you
in there I'm gonna get you someday you
rascally rabbit but first I need to cut
down more trees you're really gonna be
like this to me game sure
for I have problems yeah that took
forever I'm gonna sleep Flav thank you
oh no no I'm good I'm cold and what oh
yeah I am done and done light it up like
the fourth of July now what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna bill that's standing I need
more rocks for that don't I set em up
biscuit
take that put it on yeah okay
put out my crotch someone be to blow my
crotch oh god it's everywhere run for
the hills first where's our rainbow I'm
off fire thank you mister rainbow you're
the best goodbye hey how's it going
buddy
still dead good just checking up on you
I'll be back around again sometime soon
where's all the fish who is that the
yacht oh my god I hope there aren't any
sharks by it probably are
I'm probably gonna die but now before I
get you do you can't die on an empty
stomach but what you're doing it good
bad got you okay there we go into the
water I'm actually kind of nervous about
this shark it's not one of them seal
that I saw the other day all right
actually tell okay I lost visual just
gonna go for the hay I said to myself
that I'd punch you in the face I got it
Torche how do I punch you that's what it
found you punch you in the face you
dirty shuck bastards don't thinking you
could run away from me oh you're not
running away from me I'm I've been draw
this is a bad idea this is one of them
dumb ideas that I usually have the ones
that I usually read all right I got a
spear that I can't use oh you are big
you are a big boy just done just dunzo
just done in rings just done Z's she's
gone it's math Wow nope not today look
like you're going to take the long fall
over short pier
bother you oh no don't do that
douchebags stop being [ __ ] and swing
normally okay they also said that they
updated the range of the lighter so even
when you die in a horribly inconvenient
totally not fair way hopefully I will be
able to finally find my way out of this
damn cave it also said that they updated
the location at which you spawn to a
random location hopefully I will not
only be able to navigate out I will be
totally unharmed by vicious natives of
this island who are probably misunder
stood and actually want to be my friend
is that a floor full of skulls how
friendly I feel so loved why do I hear
noises in the dark what are you I don't
have anything do I oh my bags well I
don't like it
why do I get all the terrible terrifying
stuff okay you want to be my friend you
want to be my friend guy Oh friend
oh damn lighter cuz this is not going
well for me my friend hi how you doing
you look good
you been working out man your legs are
looking killer
oh man that core training regimen that
you got going on that's some all right
you know you and me what's their
lightning doing down here
okay going running running put the light
on I would like some light can't see oh
why did I go into the cave of nightmares
I could randomly spawn me everywhere I
randomly spawned me into the cave of our
journal nightmares oh there is not
happiness in this place there's intense
loneliness yes give me up the staff day
oh where am I going I'm running away as
fast as I can and do nothing this I'm
gonna die that's right die oh you are so
pretty lady let me count the ways about
pretty was Paul God sorry
told you okay I'm
my legacy oh good I came across a camp
where all of my friends came to die hope
I don't run into those nightmare
creatures again that would be all too
delightful I think the lesson that this
game teaches most of all is that you
should stay inside the world outside is
a very terrifying place and if you get
caught out there you will die
there is no question you will instantly
die nothing you can do can save you you
will be dead for as long as you can
remember which is a long time but I've
still got multiple tasks left to
complete on my little list here I want
to find out what that secret on the
Yanis could be some good is that a
honker that a honker honking do Boop
run and run in I can take you on if I
kill you that I can build my human
effigy and I get all these cool supplies
bring it it's time to throw down it's
time to throw down in the showdown you
know what I'm gonna build for you I have
the best idea ever
no no wait this is gonna be great you
just let me finish this it's gonna be an
homage to your superior 'no stu me
you're so much better than me in like
every way i wish that i was half as good
as you
oh no no no no please don't kill me I'm
so inferior I'm just the worst there's
no way I could ever ever compete with
the likes of you burn give me our manda
back you didn't burn their our lottery
now whoa are those your arms it better
not be walk into my flames please not
today Hulk I got to stick poking skills
up high no you're poking Ken can't deal
with this too much poke how he pokes me
poke poke ally at Heights there art yeah
yeah
Hogan but oh those are not your arms how
many are man this do you need give one
to the starving man come on Amanda
farm anak call my own oh you can't get
me Kenya Oh No what's that bonk you're
so squishy you're so squishy and full of
red juice it's tastier juice - see you
later suckers oh you can't swim oh oh
you big baby
oh this little water why you gotta be
such a baby
what fall air is not available well why
not kind of using this as my dramatic
escape from the marauding [ __ ] of oh
oh my god that's right run away you
better run
I am too strong you know what they call
me back home a loser that's what I'd do
if I fought you as you can see the
natives of the island are very friendly
and always willing to give you a hand in
your adventures oh there you all are
oh good I found you I thought you went
the other way
boy was I mistaken walk into the fire
walk into the flames please please walk
into the flames somebody walk into my
fire huh
please somebody oh what's that
you're with gummy boy there are a lot of
you why are there so many of you
go gotcha oh no you almost had me there
what yeah wow that hurt
hey play nice we're doing play nice all
right I'm outta here
you guys you guys suck what are you
doing weirdo
oh look all that trouble and I finally
made it back to exactly where I was
before with even less progress made so
great I'm so happy
can't you tell by the smile on my face I
know I'm hungry I know I need to eat I'm
working on it I was just attacked by
about a bajillion savages I need to
spear me up some fish back yeah suck on
that wonder if I can spare me up a shark
someday no please I can't carry any more
raw fish so I guess I need to cook it
goes bad why are those bad berries those
good berries just scared the crap out of
me I thought I was gonna okay let me
cook up some of my fish you have no idea
how long it takes to cook fish please
don't die
drink some booze you'll be fun and drink
drink drink drink drink up up god I'm
going to starve because I all always
already know I didn't want to burn it I
wanted to eat it I'm eating and burning
at the same time is food okay so I
didn't make many of my objectives but I
still got not a lot of time left in this
episode because it's been plagued for
way too long I've been playing for about
an hour now good for me that what is
that whoa why is it undulating oh god
what is that oh who's that
Oh kill it kill it fire what the hell is
it all right so anyway now there were
like ten bajillion years later from
starting this damn video I
suppose there's no way that I could do
that though so no I'm not gonna do that
oh gee why didn't you say so sooner I
would have loved do it build that yes
minecraft would have it's done a long
time ago turn into logs I'm the best
cool all right cool all right it's
morning
cool all right not gonna die cool all
right
get-get get-get down get-get kick it up
mom oh I can combine this I can't make
it torch oh I just made a Molotov
cocktail well it's kind of like a torch
that's kind of cool
hey was wow it's already on fire hello
rainbow what do you think I should do go
attack these sons of [ __ ] that tried
to kill me really all right well it
doesn't seem like a good idea also
doesn't seem like a good idea to keep
this Molotov lit in my hand
No all right you're the game then this
player I'm so very hungry I need some
food is that a village of cannibals I'm
gonna destroy their lives ooh them some
nice Hut she got over there it sure
would be a shame like poison things are
they it sure would be a shame if
something happened to the food I can
steal preferably not human food all
right fine you oh that is a nice
soundtrack nice bass wow what did I do
why are you hitting me I just pulled out
my ax
and my Molotov went off in my hand great
we just get some of the damn nutritional
bars from these sons of [ __ ] so I
carry on my day now this is why I like
crazy in the last episode cuz these sons
of [ __ ] worth fair to me and this
game is hard and I don't have the skill
to be able to beat bad I'm just gonna go
ahead and say it
I am not good at this whole surviving in
the woods think if I was lost on an
island
I would hope hold to all the Hopi hopes
in the world that my fans would swim all
over the ocean to try to find me and you
guys would write of course baby no yeah
no he's just imagining that just total
markiplier swing in the oceans be like
look we got like not get a boat or
anything but just all swimming around
like riding Michael Phelps in across the
ocean you guys are the best it's saving
me in my hypothetical situation of being
lost at sea but in reality I'd probably
be very dead you can't do that to me why
is my voice cracking so much well let's
see what nightmares await me in this
hellhole my friend I seem to be lost in
a whoa yes oh my goodness you're so
angry do I have anything left they can
help me probably not because my rock
acts okay that's good thanks for that
fight-or-flight this is the end this is
it it all comes down to this if I can't
beat these douchebags
I'm going to forever be lost in the
woods of the cave rock max really good
not today ladies ugh am dead apparently
it's today have your way with me
well that's the end of that everybody I
can't possibly explain how bad I am at
this game anymore I've been playing for
so long and I hope you guys have learned
an important lesson there's a lot to
this game but good luck get into it cuz
it's really hard either way this is
still an early access game looks like
the new releases are being put out maybe
other every three weeks every month I
don't know either way that's a forest
I'll play it when there's more stuff to
get do and I can actually get to it so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video